It is no secret that Amazon Dotcom is
dominating multiple aspects of our daily
lives.
We can find just about everything we
could possibly need on their site,
and if you've got Amazon Prime Yoni,
wait two days for free
delivery for our digital media.
We can read books on kindle,
listen to music on Alexa,
and we can also watch on
demand movies and TV series.
This all started with an idea that
exploded into a digital revolution.
So who is the man behind
the trillion dollar company?
Well,
on today's episode of Biographics
we're talking about Jeff Bezos.
Yeah.
On January the twelfth,
19,
64 or 17 year old girl named Jacqueline
gave birth to a baby boy named Jeffrey
Preston,
your cousin in Albuquerque,
New Mexico.
She was married to Jevs biological father,
Ted August,
and for just a one year while she was
finishing earning a high school diploma,
but their relationship,
it was not meant to last
and they got a divorce.
Jacqueline later remarried,
a man named Mike Bezos,
who was a Cuban immigrants who are
to college scholarship in the US.
They have two children together and
they also gave jeff the last name.
Bezos.
Jeff grew up in a very
loving and supportive family.
His step father,
Mike,
was very resourceful and hard working.
His motto was very loving and supportive,
and she was especially concerned about
making sure that our son got the best
education possible.
She bought jeff into a Montessori school.
The idea behind this educational method
is to allow a child to excel in their
natural talents so they choose what they
want to learn at their own pace instead
of forcing every child to learn
the same things at the same time,
Jeff was extremely
focused on his schoolwork,
even from a young age.
After the allotted time
in each subject was up,
his teachers had a hard time getting
him to move on to the next topic in
preschool.
They had to pick him up while still
sitting in his chair and move him just to
break his concentration.
Jeff Bezos spent his summer vacations
living with his grandparents and helping
them run their ranch in Texas.
His grandparents own
didn't ask dream trailer,
so they would go on long road
trip vacations together as well.
During these trips,
he would find excuses to do math problems
on a scrap of paper like their average
gas mileage and how much they
were spending on groceries
even though he helped
around the ranch with the chores.
He did not particularly enjoy the
outdoors and do you prefer to watch TV and
read books.
At a very early age,
Jeff Bezos was showing
signs that he was a genius.
His grandfather was also
a very intelligent man and
he could see the potential
in Jeff's future,
so his grandfather gave him some very
valuable advice which stuck with him for
the rest of his life.
I explained it's harder
to be kind than clever.
Cleverness is a gift.
Kindness is a choice
and choices can be hot.
You can seduce yourself with
your gifts if you're not careful.
He spent the rest of his life reminding
himself that no matter how much he
accomplished,
he would try to stay down to us.
I tell him his mother allows him to
have a workshop in their garage where he
built a solar cooker.
Huffaker often even installed a
security alarm on his bedroom door.
He was competing in science fans,
reading science fiction,
and watching episodes of star trek
on TV when he was 10 years old,
he found a teletype
computer at his school.
He and his friends found out that there
was a star trek game preprogrammed into
the system.
Gold track 73,
so he and his friends used the
computer to play this game.
This sparked his interest in computer
programming and it would carry on for the
rest of his life.
Jeff Bays,
they started his first
business in high school.
He was disappointed by
the quality of its towns,
local summer camp,
where kids would just play games outside
most of the day and not really learning
anything.
So he founded a new camp
called the dream institute.
They announced kids from the fourth,
fifth,
and sixth grade to attends and focused
on teaching children about important
works of literature in a fun,
exciting way.
The business,
it was a success and many of these
kids who are doing that summer reading,
we'd go on to get better grades in school,
not surprisingly,
he was the Valedictorian
of his high school class,
and during his graduation speech he said
that he believed that a one day human
beings would colonize
space after graduation.
He attended Princeton University and
earned a degree in computer science.
His first job was at a
startup called fit out.
While he worked there,
he was expected to fly between New York
and London nearly every week in order to
get his job done,
which was costing the company a tremendous
amount of money he ran is that this
was not the most efficient
way to run a business,
and it got into thinking about all the
different things that he would do more
efficiently if he got to run
his own company in the future.
His next job was at bankers trust,
which gave him some experience
in the financial industry.
Next,
he works for an investment firm
on Wall Street called De Shaw.
He helps to develop software
for trading stocks online.
As the years went on,
Jeff Bezos was staying on top of the
news about the growth of the Internet.
He realized that every single year
the number of people who are using the
Internet was increasing by 2000,
300 percent.
Even though the world wide
web had many naysayers,
he knew that the Internet wasn't just a
passing fad and it would become a part
of people's daily lives.
Very soon he knew early on to take
advantage of this and figured that if he
couldn't genuinely create an
online business that would
help make people's lives
easier,
it would last.
It was also was thinking about the
customer and then work from that.
Before Jeff Bezos met his wife,
Mckenzie,
he said that he was always looking for
a resource for women because he always
admired how his own parents would
work as a team in order to make their
circumstances work.
It needs a drug that he was looking
for someone to sort of like macgyver,
someone who was able to get him
out of a third world prison.
He was lucky to find out while he was
still working his job at de Shaw Mckenzie
Tuttle was a fellow princeton who was
applying to work for the fan since Jeff
Bezos was the one in charge
of hiring new candidates.
He sold her resume and
even before meeting her,
he knew that she was clearly a
very intelligent and capable women.
When she arrived for the job interview,
you felt cupid's Arrow strike
him right in the heart.
Even the office romances
are sometimes frowned upon.
They fell in love now,
even though he secretly at Mater,
he didn't want to cross the line,
so it was actually Mckinsey who made the
first move and asked him out for lunch.
They were dating for just three months
before they got engaged and they got
married in 1993.
When Jeff Bezos turned 30 years old,
they had been married for only a year.
He told his wife about his idea for an
online bookstore and that he wanted to
quit his job in order to pursue it.
They decided to leave
New York City in 1994.
Basically,
I just chose to start this company in
Seattle because it's also the location of
Microsoft,
so there was a lot of
talent in the tech industry,
living death,
and to find employees from.
It's also far cheaper to start a company
that compared to New York or silicon
valley,
they now have several children together
and they had built a rock solid
foundation together long before
Amazon Dotcom never existed.
Once the company began to do well,
Mackenzie was able to fulfill her
dream of becoming a published author.
Today,
Jeff Bezos,
he puts family first.
He says that he refuses to take any
meetings before 10:00 AM because spending
time with his family and having breakfast
with his children before they go to
school is more important
to him than anything else.
When Jeff Thins Mckenzie Bayzos first
moved down to the west coast to start
Amazon.com in 1994.
At that time,
the website only soldier used books
in his mind is Jeff Bezos imagined a
bookstore with millions of titles and he
knew that that would eventually be the
end goal of the company because the did
the accounting and he began building the
website and sourcing inventory.
In the beginning,
they ran the company out of that garage.
After receiving an order for a book,
Jeff would go to thrift stores and used
the bookshops that looking for the book
that was requested and then send it
to the customer through the mail.
If he could not find it,
he would source it from
someone else online just to
make sure that the sale went
through.
That way they were able to run the
company without using much physical space
when they were ready to hire a team to
help them run the business out of that
house,
the staff of Amazon.com,
it was only eight people.
Since the company did not have much money,
he asked his employees to
make desks out of old doors.
Even to this day,
the door desk is still a
tradition at MSN offices.
Before bringing the website live
onto the world wide web based,
they sent it to 300 of his friends so
that they could test it beforehand.
When the team was getting ready to
officially launch the site in 1995,
they set up the computer to Ding
every time that there was a sale.
In the beginning,
everyone would shout and share
every time there was a new sale,
but within just a few days there were so
many sales that they grew tired of the
noise and they had to turn it off.
The website was so popular they were
getting business through word of mouth
without paying a single
dime for press coverage.
Jeff's idea,
it was absolutely shocking and it was
clear to the team that the company would
become a success.
The reason why Amazon.com succeeded so
quickly was that Bayzos was filling a
very real need that people had.
It was the very first online bookstore
before even barnes and noble began
selling their stock on the Internet.
Ever since then,
Amazon continued to pioneer various
aspects of incorporating the internet into
people's daily lives and he says that
for seven years there was no competition
that was similar to what
he was doing in 1997 bays.
I just wanted to take Amazon.com public.
Thankfully he still had
connections on Wall Street,
so we knew exactly how to approach
investors with a business plan.
They fully admitted that he did not
actually intend to make any profit for the
first five years that the
company was operating,
Jeff Bezos gave stock options to
all of his original employees,
and this made them very motivated
to make the company succeed.
After a couple of years,
every single one of those eight
employees had become multimillionaires.
After awhile,
bases wanted to sell for
more than just books,
female to thousand random customers
asking what sorts of items they would like
to buy on the Internet.
Soon enough,
he was getting replies.
If ice comes in just about every category,
he realized that he wanted to grow Amazon
into a store that sold everything and
he began using the same
method that he had with books,
listing a product online,
buying the item in person,
and then shipping it to the customer.
Of course,
this only helped the
company grow even more,
but even after earning
millions of dollars,
Bayzos continued to drive
his beat up old Honda.
He wanted to show his employees that
he still stood by his core values of
frugality and resourcefulness.
Instead of spending that money on himself,
he reinvested the money
to make Amazon.com better.
They bought out other competing online
book region is and brought them into the
fold.
He also designed it to give anyone in
the United States the opportunity to sell
on the Amazon platform
as third party sellers,
which one made the platform stronger
because it expanded their adventury.
Every decision Jeff Bezos made for the
expanding business was with the future in
mind.
When he learned about Ebooks,
he gave the people the opportunity to
self publish their work online for the
first time and Zen and income.
Next,
he develops the kindle ereader to give
people a place to read all of their
ebooks.
When you saw on digital streaming
services becoming popular,
he jumped on that bandwagon as well
and the list of things like this,
it just goes on and on.
Today.
Amazon.com is one of the most massive
corporations in the world and they have
dipped their toes into so many different
industries at this point that it's kind
of hard to keep track.
Amazon has been criticized for putting
independent bookstores out of business.
Even major corporations like borders
books simply could not compete.
According to Amazon Dot Com.
Former manager Mike Daisy.
Amazon is designed from the
ground up to be a shock.
It's designed to dissolve and destroy
other businesses by undercutting them.
However,
Jeff Bezos argues that he should not be
blamed for the downfall of these other
businesses because the future
was coming no matter what,
whether it was him or someone else.
Jeff Bezos says that whenever he
makes a major business decision,
he imagines himself at 80 years old and
if he would be proud of his actions,
looking back,
if the answer is yes,
he listens to that intuition
and he goes for it.
By listening to his heart,
he has become one of the most
successful people in the world.
Amazon has been incredibly
successful into lots of people.
Attributed it to Jeff Bezos,
has skills in leadership.
He has a list of core
values for Amazon and see,
always abides by those rules himself.
At the end of the DOTCOM bubble,
the value of Amazon stock went from $113
per share all the way down to $6 per
share.
For many members of the original team,
they lost millions of dollars
in their stock portfolio,
and this was enough to destroy the
vast majority of those early Internet
businesses.
One of the many reasons why
Amazon survived was that
Jeff Bezos wasn't judging
the business's success on the stock price.
He knew that people were still using the
website and it was growing every single
day,
as we mentioned before.
Basically,
it's always made his customers
the number one priority.
Whenever you received a
very serious complaint,
he would never try to reprimand
his employees for making a mistake.
Instead,
he would forward a particularly troubling
customer complaints to the manager of
each department with a simple
question mark and the subject line.
According to former employees getting
one of those question mark emails was
terrifying and they would quickly do
everything they could to fix the problem
immediately.
When the issues were resolved,
bezos would simply reply with a smiley
face if he sees a bad experience that a
customer has.
He uses it as a case study to improve
the company overall and not just that one
person's individual experience.
Amazon is now available in 16 countries,
so he has had to give up much of the
power over those branches of the companies
and see you can't be everywhere at once.
Some countries are actually trying to
fend off Amazon's monopoly in certain
industries.
In France,
for example,
there is a law that no bookstore,
whether it be online or in person,
is allowed to discount a book by more
than five percent off the retail price and
they can ask you a free
shipping to entice buyers.
This way,
independent bookshops in
France still thriving.
Only time is going to tell how many
nations are going to adopt Amazon in the
future.
By a stroke of genius,
Jeff Bezos has managed to run Amazon.com
with this or to no profit despite the
fact that they are bringing in billions
of dollars in revenue every single year.
This is because he's always thinking
about the future and trying to grow the
business to keep pushing the envelope
and what is going to happen next.
Basically is still a
true trekkie at heart,
so it's really no surprise that he is
creating a private space company called
blue origin.
Just like you said during his
high school graduation speech.
He believes that someday it will be
very normal for people to be living and
working in space and he wants to be on
the forefront of that few shot at the
time that we're making this video.
Jeff Bezos is worth a hundred and 37 point
$6,000,000,000 and that makes him the
wealthiest man in all of history.
Amazon.com.
It's been valued at over a trillion
dollars and of course there is always the
chance that this wealth will grow,
but he hasn't just hoarding
well if this money to himself,
he created the Bezos family foundation
and also the world what charitable cause
he could help pay for.
He received 47,000 emails with suggestions
about where the money should go and
he spends a lot of time reading some of
the best ideas for courses that truly
matter.
He said all of the best
decisions are made with instinct,
intuition.
It's hot.
Jeff Bezos says that he wants to give
his money away to many of these charities
and invest more in startup business
ideas that will help humanity.
He decided to begin this journey by
opening tuition free Montessori preschools
and underprivileged communities so that
children can have the same opportunities
that he did,
and he also wants to open
homeless shelters that allow
an entire family to stay
together instead of splitting
men and women apart.
As time goes on,
we'll see just how much Jeff Bezos uses
his money for good and he's always open
to suggestions,
so I really hope you found
that video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every week.
Also,
if you're looking for something
else to watch right now,
click one of the videos on the screen.
That's some of the
stuff from our archives,
and as always,
thank you for watching.